when light is going through a uniform
medium like the air or as we know light
can go through vacuum so nothing at all
we imagine it going in a straight line
but we see something really interesting
happening here when it hits this glass
prism i know it just looks like a gray
triangle to you but imagine it as a
triangular piece of glass and it's
hitting it at an angle what this
animation shows us is that the path of
the light actually gets bent and not
only does it get bent but the different
frequencies of the light get bent by
different amounts now if you were to
look at this with your eyes you wouldn't
be able to see the actual waves like
we're seeing in this diagram right over
here you would just see how your brain
or how your mind perceives the various
frequencies and that's why they made the
higher frequencies here more like a
violet or a purple color and that's why
they made the lower frequencies here
more of a red color because that's how
your brain or your mind would perceive
them but you can see as as this light
goes from let's say the vacuum to this
prism to this crystal or this glass the
high frequency light gets bent more and
the low frequency light which still gets
bent gets bent less and then that
essentially spreads out all the
wavelengths when we have white light it
has all of the visible wavelengths in it
but when it hits a prism like this if
you imagine a triangular piece of glass
or crystal and it hits it at an angle
well then the different wavelengths
spread out and if you were to put a
piece of paper here you would see a
rainbow and that's actually how rainbows
are formed a bunch of water particles in
the air refract light exactly like this
this process of when light goes from one
transparent medium to another or a
vacuum to some other medium that it can
travel through that's transparent
if it hits it at an angle it can get
bent which is what we call refraction
this is why when you look at a cup of
water or at a pool at an angle you're
not seeing directly through the pool the
image gets distorted